[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour votre nouveau statut de société le
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour discuter
et débattre des sujets qui font
l'actualité alors jusqu'au 11 juillet
l'europe va vibrer au rythme de l'euro
de football après deux saisons chamboulé
en raison de l'épidémie de covile 19
les fans et pratiquant retrouvent leurs
habitudes et les yvelines ont une
tradition forte avec le ballon rond
alors sont elles mêmes une terre de
football on en parle avec aux invités
valérie tardivel bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes secrétaire général du district des
yvelines de football et thierry moreau
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur
sportif du football olympique plaisir
oies et on va commencer justement que
cette question valérie tardivel est ce
que les yvelines sont une terre de
football
ben écoute et oui déjà par le biais de
clairefontaine qui est située dans les
yvelines le très beau site de
clairefontaine avec là où s'entraînent
les bleus voilà déjà par le biais de ça
et puis on a des grands joueurs qui sont
issus des yvelines qui oeuvrent
actuellement en équipe de france
notamment qui peine les comme année puis
rabiot donc voilà le vrai que les noms
déjà peinte c'est un sentiment que
partage et thierry moreau oui tout à
fait je pense que c'est un département
qui est très très dynamique et qu'elle
le football tient une place importante
il ya énormément de pratiquants
puisqu'il semble que le district d
hygiène et le deuxième district en
nombre de licenciés de la ville de paris
donc ça c'est significatif
alors ces deux dernières saisons elles
ont été mouvementée en raison de la
crise sanitaire ça n'aura échappé à
personne je reste avec vous et thierry
moreau est-ce qu'il a fallu retrouver
les sensations et que vos licenciés est
ce que vous en avez perdu aussi lors de
cette saison tout à fait je pense qu'il
faut distinguer les deux saisons la
saison en 2019 2020 qui est vraiment été
interrompue
en raison du grand du confinement assez
long qui a eu lieu
et puis cette saison qui a été un petit
peu différente puisque la pratique a été
très très encadré mais qu'elle a quand
même pu perdurer
donc effectivement entre les deux
saisons j'ai eu un plaisir on a perdu à
peu près 80 licenciés principalement
chez dans les petites catégories et je
pense que les gens rient un petit peu
peur de réinscrire les enfants compte
tenu du contexte sanitaire
valérie tardivel c'est une tendance que
vous voyez sur tout le département dans
les districts oui tout à fait nous au
niveau district on l'a constaté
également une baisse importante
on peut dire avant avant la pandémie et
jusqu'à maintenant on a mené à une
baisse de 11,3 pour cent qui équivaut à
peu près à 4004 700 licenciés donc c'est
énorme je vous parle dans le foot mais
je pense que dans les autres sports
c'est exactement pareil et notamment
comme le disait monsieur moreau une
baisse au niveau du foot animation dans
des tout petits
est ce que vous avez voulu là ça a
repris à ce que vous allez proposer des
animations notamment au district pour
faire revenir peut-être les plus jeunes
pour redonner confiance
oui effectivement dans qu'aux districts
appartient du 19 mai où on a eu droit de
refaire une pratique sportive au niveau
des jeunes
donc on a laissé un petit peu les clubs
se retourner et là actuellement est
organisé pendant tout le mois de juin
donc des des actions de foot c'est pas
des compétitions qui reprennent les cds
action plutôt des plateaux au niveau du
foot animation ainsi que des rencontres
au niveau des catégories jeunes
notamment eu 14 u15 et u14 u16 et u18
pardo à plaisir aussi j'imagine on a
revu
un petit peu tout le planning est ce
qu'on est plus sûr du foot presque
plaisir loisirs où on joue vraiment à
fond non là il s'agit principalement de
reprendre des sensations de redécouvrir
le plaisir d'affronter des équipes
adverses
alors l'objectif compétitif il est
complètement absent pour l'instant on
verra ça à la reprise de la nouvelle
saison
oui c'est ça on on remet les corps en
route avant de se dire en septembre en
octobre prochain on y va et cette fois
on espère que ça ne s'arrête plus tout à
fait vraiment on prend plaisir à re
pratiquer cette chose qu'on avait un pas
j'irai pas oublié mes gants par la
contrainte on avait été obligé de mettre
un petit peu de côté et c'est vraiment
le plaisir qui domine avant tout alors
les sensations sont peut-être pas encore
sur le terrain mais il y en a beaucoup
en ce moment puisque depuis le 11 juin
le roux a débuté c'est un mois de
compétition européenne
j'imagine que vous êtes tous les deux
très attentif aux différents matchs qui
vont rythmer ce mois valérie tardivel
est ce que vous espérez aussi que ça va
relancer le sport amateur
bien sûr déjà l'équipe de france nous a
montré c'était bien parti donc je compte
sur eux pour aller jusqu'au bout au
niveau de l'euro et à chaque compétition
importante de l'équipe de france quand
il ya une victoire au bout
nous on a constaté en tant que district
et tous les clubs également qu'il ya une
augmentation du nombre des licenciés
donc ça ça va être important à l'euro
2016 à la coupe du monde 2018 même la
coupe du monde 2019
chez les filles qui étaient organisées
en france on revint que ça au niveau des
filles on a augmenté l'effectif de 19%
donc voyez c'est un impact réel sur le
sur le nombre de licenciés donc on y
croit thierry moreau vous le voyez aussi
à plaisir ça vient plus facilement après
les grandes compétitions
tout à fait c'est vraiment sont des
événements qui sont assez les moteurs et
qui suscite un grand engouement et ça
permet de toucher un public qu'on
n'avait pas forcément précédemment
effectivement ça
cela nous amène beaucoup de nouveaux
licenciés en général ce que tu as et
compétition surtout quand l'équipe de
france performe bien ça vous amène quels
types les plus jeunes où toutes les
générations finalement non un peu tous
les publics mais quand même
principalement des jeunes qui qui
découvre le football à la télé qui ont
envie de de s'essayer à la pratique
alors on l'a dit un petit peu au début
il y a la particularité dans les
yvelines c'est le district qui possède
le centre d'entraînement des bleus à
clairefontaine c'est bien sûr dans les
yvelines
j'imagine valérie tardivel que c'est un
bel écrin ah oui à ça pour ceux qui
connaissent clairefontaine c'est
magnifique c'est déjà situé un peu à
l'écart de la ville c'est en plein de
campagne les bleus sont sont dans un
cadre magnifique je le redis encore les
installations sont au top electric
medical moment il ya tout le staff qui
en place et là ils sont vraiment bien
pour se mettre au vert et préparer au
mieux l'euro est ce que des joueurs
yvelinois ils vont s que les amateurs
peuvent y aller peuvent découvrir cet
écrin où c'est vraiment un cocon qui
réservé aux pros sarah cocan qui est
réservé aux pros qui sert également
accueillir d'autres d'autres sociétés
par exemple nous au niveau du district
nous faisons de formation des arbitres à
clairefontaine on peut profiter de ce
lieu qui est magnifique et voilà thierry
moreau c'est un rêve un jour d'aller
d'aller à clairefontaine d'emmener ses
joueurs voir le lieu
pour moi c'est pas tout à fait un rêve
puisque est partie de la commission
technique du district des yvelines dans
le cadre des sélections la préparation
des sélections évinoise u14 u15
on a l'occasion de fréquenter le centre
de clairefontaine
on est vraiment très chanceux ce niveau
là oui donc l'écrin sous un petit peu
alors on l'a dit aussi quelques jours
j'en avais citer quelqu'un à la
rédaction on disait aussi nicolas anelka
ratera de keke théâtre à ben arfa à
versailles et mbaye niang qui était aux
mureaux plus possible jean kévin
augustin à plaisir en fait où on forme
aussi des futurs pros valérie tardivel
ben oui quand vous pouvez le voir
non non au niveau des formations on a
une grande équipe de formation au niveau
du district qui qui fait qui permet aux
au foot amateur un peu de se structurer
au club de se structurer sur tout et
faire passer des diplômes aux encadrants
et thierry moreau est ce que c'est des
noms qui font ces les noms qui font
rêver les enfants
c'est les bleus de manière générale est
ce qu'au club où vous repérer des futurs
griezmann défiguré un bape et comment ça
se passe nous on a la chance d'être un
club formateur qui a sorti quelques
quelques joueurs qui sont qui accèdent
au niveau professionnel donc
effectivement ce sont des exemples pour
les plus jeunes on n'est pas dans la
démarche de sortie en forcément des
joueurs professionnels l'idée pour nous
c'est plus d'apprendre aux enfants à
jouer à bien jouer si possible et puis
après s'ils ont vraiment des qualités au
dessus de la moyenne d' d'accéder à un
statut un petit peu supérieure mais
l'idée majeure c'est pas au départ de
les amener vers le professionnalisme
c'est le plaisir du jeu avant tout tout
à fait et puis on parle de ceux qui se
sont formés sur le terrain on a donc
aussi clairefontaine mais lors de l'euro
2016 la russie et l'irlande avaient leur
camp d'entraînement à versailles avec
rossi sur scène croatie qui a aussi
accueilli l'équipe féminine des
etats-unis
comment est ce qu'on explique un tel
attrait du territoire valérie tardive
ben peut-être parce que c'est bien
organisé ses proches de paris voilà ça
peut être une des raisons qui incitent
les ce type d'événement alors le sport
c'est très souvent un moment de
convivialité et même quand on n'est pas
directement sur le stade l'occasion de
se retrouver aussi autour d'un verre
dans un bar avec la crise l'organisation
est chamboulée je vous propose qu'on
écoute des professionnels qui sont
habitués à la retransmission des matchs
ça va être un petit peu compliqué on va
commencer par une salle admis jauge où
on fera pas de restauration intérieure
etc on diffusera les matchs en attendant
le futur si ça va plus loin on espère
pouvoir mettre des écrans dehors pour
que ce soit plus convivial et médias et
c'est à dire que l'addition 5 francs
soit plus pratique pour nous on est
largement habitué depuis 98 retransmet
tous les matchs toutes les
tous les grands événements sportifs donc
ça on a l'habitude par contre on a moins
l'habitude de le faire avec
avec le comique donc il ya pas mal de
l'adaptation à faire donc au niveau des
jauges à l'intérieur donc réduire un peu
les
augmenter les espaces plutôt entre les
personnes et éviter qu'elles aient
personnes debout dans la salle donc tout
le monde sera tout le monde sera assis
avec l'extension de la terrasse qu'on a
juste ici et puis nos deux salles à
l'intérieur on peut aller jusqu'à 120
personnes quoi donc ça fait ça fait pas
mal sachant que des fois et que les
fortes affluences du macho avant on
avait le droit forcément d'être un peu
plus serré d'être debout les
les uns contre les autres là on va
perdre un petit peu de monde on pouvait
monter jusqu'à 200 les soirs de
l'histoire de deux grands matches fois
et là je vais m'adresser aux fans et pas
nécessairement directeur sportif et à la
secrétaire générale comment vous vivez
vous cet euro oui bah écoutez moi je
suis de près on fait même au niveau des
districts on a un petit une petite
application où on peut parier sur les
matches donc on se fait des petits
challenge on suit de près le ro
évidemment l'équipe de france en tête
par on attend samedi avec impatience et
vous monsieur moreau comment vous suivez
vous personnellement cet euro comme le
disait madame tardivel
comme je fais partie de la commission
technique du district le jeu je
participe à justement son petit concours
de pronostics et puis sinon comme un
amateur de football lord a qui regardent
les matchs qui sont télévisés en fait et
avec le club justement un plaisir est ce
que vous envisagez des retransmissions
ensemble des soirées un peu spécial
alors là on va organiser une mini
événement là pour une des catégories
très prochainement pour les u10 mais on
a des grosses restrictions au niveau
d'utilisation du club house donc ça nous
permet pas de faire quelque chose
d'envergure c'est donc peut-être que
cette année on vivra plus tôt devant sa
télé je vous propose qu'on s'arrête sur
ce moment là le statut de société est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et on suit
l'équipe de france
il
[Musique]